all right you probably didn't hear about
this in the mainstream media but Isis
had a huge rally in Gaza yesterday that
was sort of co-sponsored or at least
allowed by Hamas and the interesting
thing about this is that it was just
barely a month ago that France voted for
a Palestinian state at the Security
Council at the UN so you'd think that
maybe the people of Gaza would be a
little more sympathetic to what's going
on in France with the shooting and the
Charlie Hebdo thing and all that but
that doesn't appear to be let's say
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so this appears to be the
first sort of big isis rally in gaza so
yeah they're burning french flags
this is the same country that voted with
them at the Security Council now I get
it they're upset about the the cartoon
thing but this seems extremely
short-sighted not that these guys really
have like a long do they have meetings
where they've sort of lay out how are we
gonna do this guys and what looks like
this just looks so terrible for them I
just it's hard to understand what the
goal is here like the most terrible
thing that's happened to be ahead to
Japanese citizens right now like judge
be a little bit worse than burning the
French flag when I look at this it makes
it appeals to the worst senses in me it
makes me become this xenophobic kook it
makes me become like an old drunk uncle
at Thanksgiving he was like burn them
off the map because just like what you
were saying is you're like okay so we
just told you you you can be in God's
that we the French supported you the
French are giving you a lot more
depression voted you or a state at the
UN Security about you yeah and now
you're like well now we're gonna burn
your flag so it's just like basically
sometimes when I look at this I'm like
this is like when you you have family
members there's me that just need a
hobby
like there it's like they have nothing
they've no real information they have
nothing better to do they get pissed off
they burn a flag it sounds like so
simple but I'm just so tired of watching
people that just contradict themselves
and just want violence and to burn a
flag and to complain it's just it's like
just stop bitching go away and I'm
becoming the xenophobic crazy person I
don't blow them off the map when I look
at it I understand why people get that
ignorant inclination to go oh just pop
them right so how much in this not even
in a weird way not that I'm gonna defend
Isis at all but in a weird way that this
is actually Hamas is fault because
nobody can speak about them right you're
not allowed to speak about them so then
the people rally to make to attack
France because it's their only way of
getting out some frustration like the
people that guys are their frustration
in my opinion should be with Hamas
maybe with Israel over there's no
logical thought here these are people
it's like lizard brain mentality where
wherever there's a certain urge or a
thought you just rush to be angry or
happy or excited or mad
whatever just pops into your head this
isn't critical thinking skills this
isn't well-thought-out plans of people
this is a population of people that have
nothing reacting well I just can't
decide if it's an inconsistency or if
it's just something that I can't at all
in any way empathize with it like oh no
freedom of press no freedom of speech no
freedom for women for gays for whatever
like all that's fine but like don't make
fun of the Prophet right or you know
anything goes that is like and that that
as the highest priority honor to defend
I can't relate to right I can't I can't
relate to right so and this goes to what
we were talking about earlier during the
State of the Union part but you want to
empathize with these people and then
there's that disconnect there yes yeah
so we have a quote from one of the
protesters and I thought it kind of just
sums up the whole damn thing just pretty
perfectly today we are telling France
and world countries that while Islam
orders us to respect all religions it
also orders us to punish and kill those
who assault and offend Islam's Prophet
Mohammed I added a little cartoonish
reading there but doesn't that get to it
right there like on one hand we're
supposed to respect you but also if you
don't respect us the way we want to be
respected we will kill you this is an
absolute contradiction and there's no
way you can deal with people that even
in their official statements about
things directly contradict themselves
and I understand that Americans
contradict ourselves all the time birth
and practice and theory of what we do
but you have it right they're like oh
we're supposed to respect you but you
know if you do anything impress us off
we're gonna literally kill you yeah but
like yes that also exists in every other
major religion like there are dangerous
right now and there's not you know a lot
of Jews running around and honestly this
is just a Muslim problem with this
little sect of people have decided to
take Islam extremely seriously and
literally are contradicting their own
beliefs so it doesn't they're just
they're right so they're but we're going
to kill you so there is a look
Christianity did a lot of bad [ __ ] and
went through its Reformation so it's on
the other side of that now and all
religions do all kinds of crazy [ __ ] but
there is a difference turn on Family Guy
every episode has Jesus there's an
episode where Jesus is literally sponge
bathing with sexy music playing in the
background porn music as Stewie's
watching no one's going up the Fox
Network we're airing that like they did
with Charlie about exactly so what do
now again it's not what do we do about
it but what are they supposed to do
about it over there I guess is the
question
well for one Hamas could stop saying
that Isis isn't their problem and that
they're not related to Isis and that
well they sanction this thing so there
they were like okay like yes protesting
France is like understandable whereas
basic human rights not yeah all
religions have their hypocrisy that way
that's the same thing as Christians
saying that they're very peaceful but
then you know bombing an abortion clinic
and those are extreme examples I know
that's not the norm
but then it does take the rest of the
the middle of the population like if I
if somebody claims under the name of
Christianity that there's no people
shouldn't have abortions ago bombs the
clinic people are like whoa whoa that
has nothing to do with us that person is
crazy and mysteries up representing us
and I think the problem is that most
people want to hear that from more
Muslims but it's also not their
responsibility to go around apologizing
for their whole religion so right
there's really no answer there except
for what I said in the beginning which
is [ __ ] those guys but people about
they're killing people and beheading
people come on all right I think we can
all agree on that if you're reading
anyone yeah high five that was a subtle
high five if you're beheading people and
you're burning French flags and what
else go [ __ ] yourself like that right
there
sorry
[Music]